le temps d'une journée ce sont les rois
ils font des centaines en situation
d'itinérance ou bien moins nantis avoir
droit à un copieux repas chauds
l'événement en est à sa 141ème année
pour linda hervé l'un des rares couples
à fréquenter l'accueil bonneau
c'est une première visite au dîner des
rois la vie des fois réseau des
surprises d'autres sont des habitués
jean louis paquet a passé plus de deux
ans dans la rue depuis peu l'accueil
bonneau lui a permis de retrouver un
logement mais il tenait malgré tout à
participer au traditionnel dîner miroir
ladakh besoin de sortir mais
georgie avec mitchum intervenants
aujourd'hui c'est une façon de leur dire
qu'on est là qu'on veut qu'ils sentent
spécial qu'on les oublie pas comme le
veut la tradition la mairesse de
montréal sert les repas aux convives une
occasion pour l'organisme de réitérer
son besoin criant pour plus de
ressources
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes
en situation d'itinérance encore en
situation d'itinérance chronique
donc il faut y mettre fin on sait
comment faire ça prend beaucoup de
solutions de logement avec
l'accompagnement psychosocial
c'est vrai qu'elle est besoin et sans
gras et moi je pense que notre travail
est complémentaire aux gouvernements aux
administrations dont font foi les
soutenir la mairesse affirme qu'elle
entend les revendications du milieu
communautaire dont elle est issue
ça me rappelle en fait à chaque année à
quel point notre objectif de 12
logements abordables et sociale est
nécessaire dès mardi une nouvelle mesure
d'urgence sera mise en place pour les
personnes en situation d'itinérance ici
dans l'ancien hôpital royal victoria 80
lits seront installés et ce jusqu'à la
fin du mois d'avril
ici qui me permettra au canada montréal